هذا السوق يعتبر من الاسواق المهمه هنا في
بحري سوق سعد قشر الذي يعتبر من اهم
الاسواق
للملابس
هذا سوق تعرض لعمليات نهب والسلب من
متفلتين بسبب السيوله الامنيه في المنطقه
تكاد محتويات السوق كما ترونها الان امامي
اغلبيه المتاجر في هذا السوق تعرضت
عمليات السهم
سلبي ونهب وعدد كبير من المحاله التجاريه
اخذت اجزاء من بضاعتها في هذا السوق ما
زلنا نسمع كما تسمعون الان
اصوات مضادات الطائرات في هذه المنطقه هذه
المنطقه عموما في بحري ووسط بحري كنا نسمع
تحليق الطائرات بصوره مستمره ومضادات
الطائرات تعمل من قبل القوات الدعم السريع
لابعاد سلاح الجو المناطق
التي هم فيها
هذا الجو من بعد الظهر تقريبا مستمر على
هذه الحاله عمليه
المواجهه في منطقه بحرية تتركز على
العمليات المبنيه على الاشتباك عن بعد عبر
القاذفات وعبر المدفعيه وعبر سلاح الجو في
هذه المنطقه خلال الايام الثلاثه الماضيه
التي كنا فيها على ان الجو في الوقت
الصباحي كان نوعا ما ليست هناك عمليات
اشتباكات المقارنه بالايام الماضيه لكنه
في الفتره الاخيره تحرك نوعا ما ازدادت
الطلعات قوات
السلاح الجو السوداني في عدد من المناطق
هذه طلعه جويه الان طائره
هي فوقنا مباشره
تسمعونها وتحاول مضادات الطائرات ببعادها
من المنطقه عموما بعضت من التجار عادوا
الى هذا السوق لمعرفه احواله ومعرفه ما
اذا كان قد
وتبقى لهم منهم شيء بعض النساء يبدو لي
انهم يجمعون امتعتهم التي تبقت من السوق
للذهابها الى مناطق امنه
السوق يعني حسب ما نراه الان عدد كبير من
المتاجر فيه
افرقت
ونلاحظ بقايا الامتعه على على الارض منها
ما تم نهبه منها ما بقي على العموم هذه
السيوله الامنيه ربما جاءت نتيجه
الاوضاع التي والاضطرابات التي تعيشها
الخرطوم بحري خلال الفتره الماضيه
وهذا جزء من افرازات
المواجهات
وما جرى في هذه المناطق